CBS was on we have it on the preface II
that on CBS you talked about being
abandoned and that kind of freaks you
out the idea that you might do it the
idea that I might talk about it on TV
the idea that you're like we're
concerned that you would do yeah yeah
well the I was watching that I love that
you told him you're like because what
you get into it you're like I don't know
if I want to talk about this on CBS this
morning
actually started to get a little
emotional because I haven't really
addressed it and it completely came up
organically I mean that's like a
45-minute hour long interview that they
chopped up in the six minutes no but but
once we got into it was it was odd and I
was I was like keeping my [ __ ] together
because I haven't really talked about
but it was the idea because a lot of
what anchors the new special is that I
have a kid never had a kid before so
that he that was kind of a thrust of the
interview too and then and just sort of
organically started talking about how
and this is true like I always I always
wanted kids but I was reluctant because
I wondered still do whether I have that
thing in me that my dad had which
allowed him just to walk away from three
kids and a wife and just to leave and go
ma'am not this isn't my thing
how old is your kid now um how old were
you in that I was 10 some reason on the
CBS thing they said I was a teenager but
I was 10 and my I have two younger
sisters and they would have been eight
and five and my daughter now is a little
over two so at two I mean could you even
conceive of doing that no not at all
Ryan I well no that's not true in my
darkest recesses I can conceive of it I
can imagine it I've got a pretty good
imagination I didn't imagine that but it
was about the justification for it you
know the right because what he didn't
just leave he just left and didn't stay
in touch and went far away and left us
in severe debt he was really
irresponsible and we were moving around
constantly he'd get fired a lot and he
it was that it's one of the things that
bothers me so much about Trump as my dad
has those qualities he's very
narcissistic nothing is ever his fault
you know he will make he's just a
pathological liar putting himself in a
greater light you know when you can you
know objectively look back and go well
that's not true you you're completely
that fault here yeah and and just the
idea to talk to him says yeah I guess I
don't talk to him since I was 19
that was the there were there were you
know cuz I still had I was 10 and I
still had that kind of dad worship
things and I and my mom was never the
kind of person go you're your dad's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you know and she had every reason to but
she didn't do that and so until I was
like 16 17 when it started to kind of
the the veil was pulled slowly I mean I
thought my dad was [ __ ] balls man and
he was living this cool life and he was
and he was also personality was very
different from my mom my mom was very
bookish and antisocial and awkward and
intellectual my dad was the complete
opposite wasn't very street smart but
not smart smart and was very affable and
outgoing and and gregarious and and life
of the party kind of guy complete
opposites and and I don't know why I
brought that up but uh you I just liked
him I still liked him he was a cool guy
and I actually went to live with him in
Arizona I went when I was 13 13 so I'm
like that 14 maybe and we were and he
had no money and no job and we were
eating vending machine snacks cuz he
knew a guy who filled vending machines
so he had Boston baked beans I'll never
forget this it was about four or five
month period in Scottsdale Arizona
initially we were staying in a guest
room somebody's house and the mom and
the daughters liked us and the stepdad
got it immediately I think I have only
got this in retrospect my stepdad the
their stepdad was like knew my dad was
scamming him and just full of [ __ ] and
and then we were kind of kicked out of
there we went to the obvious a long
story it's a long I'll say for the
memoir 19 did you you didn't do you want
to talk to him as he did oh no not at
all no he's alive he's here in New York
I have not seen him since I was 19 and
and I talked I I can tell you the exact
thing that made me go it's just too long
to bring up here was like that's it
that's enough and I told my sister was
on the phone with him he had called and
I said tell him I don't want to speak
them anymore and he said I'll never
forget this and I quote that's alright
the only time he ever talks to me is
when he wants money which is like the
most insane yeah why first of all he had
no money he never gave us any money took
my bar mitzvah money Wow yeah
he I mean it's crazy the way he but that
does it yeah like you're the villain
yeah because all you have to do it yeah
all I the only time oh it's it's just
the literally the exact opposite of the
truth Wow and and when he said that just
sealed it one more Jim and Sam catch up
with full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM Adam